the crisis continues for America's
newspaper industry just this month
McClatchy owner of the Miami Herald the
Kansas City Star and other papers filed
for bankruptcy and will undergo
restructuring
McClatchy got its start in Sacramento
California not far away one small paper
has managed to survive for more than a
century and a half and now with a new an
unlikely editor at the helm John
Blackstone has the story down evil
California is a gold rush town that in
the mid 1800s was home to about 5,000
people
that's when down evils weekly newspaper
the mountain messenger first rolled off
the presses making it California's
oldest weekly newspaper even Mark Twain
once wrote for the messenger for the
past thirty years its owner
editor and delivery manager has been
dawn Russell man with a ready laugh who
these days is even happier than usual
Russell was ready to retire but nobody
wanted to buy the paper then Carl Butz
showed up and I'm just delighted that I
found somebody stupid enough to take it
over buts who retired two down evil
about a decade ago cancelled a long
vacation he'd been planning and decided
to invest in the mountain messenger
instead even though he had no previous
newspaper experience I thought God if
I'm going around the world and the
papers gone I'm gonna feel guilty for
the rest of my life when you bought the
paper the headlines say something like
sucker found pigeon I think yeah owning
the Mountain messenger means doing just
about everything deadlines here at
Wednesday afternoon as Butz learned when
Russell took him to pick up the paper
hot off the presses and start delivering
it to newspaper boxes around the county
there you go
why is the paper so important to town
evil this past year the bank went away
the gas station has been closed you know
that the town is like
local papers can be something to hold
with bind together a community but has
no plans to modernize California's
oldest weekly newspaper are you gonna
have an online edition no he's not
impressed by news posted on Facebook I
mean who's gonna be looking at those
posts that somebody made 50 years from
now nobody but if we put it on paper
it's gonna exist and they didn't really
fill Dawn's shoes you got to work in
your laughs a little bit okay yeah I
can't do as his laughs no buts maybe a
pigeon but he's also a savior for CBS
this morning Saturday John Blackstone
San Francisco great laugh and great yeah
wonderful story by John Blackstone and
Chris Weicker Congrats guys